Hi I'm Kagure Kabue I'm from Kenya originally
but I live in San Francisco now. I have
darkly pigmented skin and I lived in an area
that had a high prevalence for sickle cell anemia.
First of all Kenya is in East Africa and
it's right under the horn of Africa. So under
Somalia and above Tanzania. And we have the Indian
Ocean to our east. So, if you're closer to
the coast it's much hotter. It's just hot at the coast, especially in January.
>> Mm-hm.
>> and we're right on the equator. The country is actually almost split
in half by the line, equator line and if you live up in the
highlands, like I do, which is on the slopes of Mount Kenya, the temperature
doesn't vary much, so it will only be a few degrees celsius different
from morning to evening.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so you can wear a sweater or not, if you want, or not.
>> And it's, it's beautiful. You should check
out the Kenyan government website for more information.
[LAUGH]
Lots of Lions and.
>> People in different continents on the
globe have different color skin, and that
is caused by the different amounts of
melanin that they have deposited by melanocytes
into the, the skin itself. so give us some, some idea, you
know in Kenya, are most people, do they have dark skin? Do they have light skin?
>> I would say most people have dark skin.
because I guess its, is it a sliding
scale? What's, what's dark skin and what's not
dark skin? For most people would probably be
on the end where your skin is considered dark.
>> Mm hm.
>> I had, the advantage or disadvantage of going
to a s-, an international school when I was
younger. And so, there were a lot of Europeans,
or people who were both European and African descent.
And so I don't know when I first
realized the difference. I don't remember, except maybe
when I came here and the absolute opposite
was happening where I was suddenly the minority whereas
where I grew up people with lighter skin
pigmentation were the minority. And so, I don't
know, I think that was my first time
to actually realize, is when I moved here in
2008 that oh my goodness, this plane is full of people who do not look like me.
>> Skin color is such an easy trait for people to latch on to. You
know, they associate lots of other things with
it. historically, I think this has always been
true. Do you think that in general
and you can speak from your perspective growing
up in Kenya. Or even from your experience
in San Francisco. Do you think you know,
your generation or the current generation's
perspective on skin color is different from
past generations in a, in a, in a better or a worse way?
>> I think it's, I think it's better, but
it's also very complicated because there's that sort of
love hate relationship that comes with a country or
a people who've been enslaved or colonized. Where you end
up either identifying because you identify, you connect those two traits,
you connect the wealth and the success to the skin pigmentation.
And so I hope to think that in a reverse situation,
where skin pigmentation someone with darker
skin pigmentation had colonized a country
[LAUGH]
that was full of Like, an African person like
Chaka Zulu went to I don't know, Britain or something,
and colonize them, that the opposite would happen and
everybody would be outside trying to tan. And I know,
[LAUGH]
I don't know if that would happen. But you
know I'd like to think that that's how this
is broken down. It's not because one is better
or worse than the other. It's just historically there has
been a correlation or a connection between these two.
And so people have tend to identify one with success
and one with failure. It just so happens that
that's how it went down at this period in history.
>> I really like that thought experiment.
That's a really good thought experiment to do.
>> Right.
>> Do you think of skin color, skin pigmentation,
as a positive or a negative trait in any way?
>> I think skin color can have positives. I
don't think of it is negative or positive specifically.
>> Mm hm.
>> But I do know that, when I go out
in the sun. I have the advantage of not burning. Or,
I know that I'm less likely to get
skin cancer than someone with lighter skin pigmentation.
>> Mm hm.
>> But on the other side, I do know that. It, you
do need the sun in order for your body to produce vitamin D.
>> mm.
>> And in that case, if you have a higher, skin you be, have darker
skin pigmentation then, your less, you're more
likely to not have the ability to produce
enough Vitamin D.
>> Right, exactly. And I know that there's some people
who actually have to take Vitamin D supplements, or they
actually have to be told to go out into the
sun more to get enough sunlight, so that they can make
enough Vitamin D. A lot of people think differently about
skin color. Some people, it's a big deal other people
it's not a big deal. If you could give advice,
or just say anything speaking to that idea and people about
whether or not skin color is a big deal or
not. what would you say, or what advice would you give?
>> I think the advice I'd give is that it shouldn't
matter. It would be naive of me to say that you should ignore it because
others are not ignoring it. And so you should be aware of how
others will treat you. But all in all it doesn't, it shouldn't change who,
it doesn't change who you are on the
inside. It's a genetic trait that simply dictates
what the color of your skin and so,
after that It may have its biological advantages or
disadvantages. But in the end, it doesn't, it
doesn't, your skin color is not your ethnicity. It
doesn't your race. Race is a social construct.
And so, it doesn't change who you are on
the inside. It really shouldn't matter. And it would be great to say that
it doesn't matter but to some it does. My advice would be to be who you are.